hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt ich bin gerade in der türkei im
kumpel des istrischen antalya und alanya
by side und vielleicht erinnert ihr euch
an diesen gladiator spies den hatte ich
letztes jahr schon mal gezeigt denn ich
bin gerade eben restaurant simeon bei
mcallister besitzer des restaurants und
außerdem madonna aus der dicken
restaurant aber noch drei andere männer
war dabei schwer sich herzlich
willkommen
die sprache verschlagen
und wir möchten heute eine spezialität
machen und zwar gibt es hier so ein
richtig tolles das heer ein warmes eis
ich hatte auch letztes jahr schon mal
davon berichtet obwohl es eigentlich mal
nachmachen
aber ich habe mir gedacht komm das
machen wir jetzt dieses mal direkt in
der küche direkt einem chef
europäisches thema am besten direkt in
die küche rein ich zeige euch die
zutaten und dann gibts auch direkt los
an zutaten brauchen wir uns für drei
personen etwas butter das sind ungefähr
30 gramm
dann habe ich ihr walnüssen etwa 40
kommt
50 steigen das sind getrocknete bereits
klein geschnittenes und zu ungefähr 100
milliliter sahne und zum servieren
später haben wir uns so einen länglichen
teller ausgesucht weil es dann ganz
schön aussieht wenn man es darauf an
rüstet ihr könnt es jetzt entweder in
einer beschichteten pfanne machen aber
in so einem kleinen geschichten geben
wir zuerst die butter rein
wir haben jetzt schon die pfanne auf
mittlere stufe fahrerei alles dann kommt
auch direkt zeigen mit der so und das
wird durch stecken und dann schmilzt es
so ein bisschen da drinnen
karamellisiert auch ein bisschen der
zucker da drin
am besten da ist so eine hohe pfanne
weil es nicht könnte das nicht so schön
schwenken dann fällt nämlich alles raus
gerd michael abel soll in dem stummfilm
er redet grad nix mit meter bei cannabis
deutsch
jetzt gehen wir noch die wahl mit 1
nochmal schwenken
dass mir die wahl bisschen anrösten und
wenn ihr halt letzten haben halt einfach
ein kochlöffel und wird durch das geht
auch
und jetzt lässt sich das ab mit der
sahne
jetzt kocht es ein bisschen ein
das riecht jetzt schon richtig gut
wissler einkochen lassen dann wird es
auch schon dickflüssig
jetzt haben jetzt einreduzieren lassen
als ich sehe dass es ist schön
dickflüssig jetzt gibt es direkt auf dem
servierteller richtig schön
dann haben wir uns hier schon mal das
eis rausgeholt und zwar formt daraus
kugeln zum beispiel auch mit einem eis
portionierer friert sie nochmal ein dann
schmilzt es nämlich nicht so schnell und
dann hier schön drauf platzieren
zusammen mit vier kugeln drauf
und jetzt noch mit ein bisschen wahllos
und dekorieren und gleich kommt noch
eine sally zutat mit dazu und zwar gebe
ich gleich das sind mit rein
und ich habe für das leckere eis
zubereitet jetzt kann's gegessen werden
natürlich schmilzt das eis ziemlich
schnell weil die so sehr warm ist aber
nach machen wollt schaut einfach auf
meinem blog vorbei - blog.de
das schreibe ich nochmal genauer ein und
die portion reicht jetzt eigentlich für
23 personen am besten löst ihr euch dann
hier die soße ein bisschen mit frau und
ihr könnt diesen schmelz vorgang bisher
reduzieren wenn ihr zum beispiel erst am
ziel stand das eis drauf gibt also das
wäre eigentlich die bessere möglichkeit
und wir hatten jetzt leider keinen
zimtpulver deswegen erstens ohne
anspruch ohne sehr guten appetit